hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna talk
about my new obsession HBO's new series
based on Watchmen this will be a short
video where I tell you why I think you
should read the original work first
because I'm excited about the series I
plan on making a lot of videos about it
and I believe you'll be better served if
you read the original story yourself
rather than having me spoil it for you
just so you know I'm not a comic book
guy in fact I can't tell you a comic
series I've read before Watchmen which I
didn't read until I heard that HBO is
creating a series about it I don't say
this to sound cool I just never got into
them I lived in books when I was a kid
reading was literally my favorite
pastime but I guess no one ever turned
me on to comics or else I probably would
have read those too that said I'm not a
big fan of all the new blockbuster comic
based movies that seem to come out every
weekend at this point they make for good
eye candy and a predictable payoff from
the ones I've seen but I haven't gotten
sucked into the world of comics that
they're based on again not trying to
sound cool here obviously these
franchises provide a lot of
entertainment to a lot of people they're
just not my cup of tea
why Watchmen then well my reasoning for
reading it was simple I have a youtube
channel and was looking for content to
cover HBO series are generally a cut
above most other networks and I really
enjoyed the leftovers which was the last
project Watchmen showrunner Damon
Lindelof worked on for the network
because I was never into comics I had
zero expectations going in and I think
that played a big part in me getting
hooked on the series that and of course
the fact that it's a good story which is
why I'm making the video telling you
that I think you should read it rather
than just making a trailer breakdown
about what's out about the show first in
order to explain the trailer and what
the series might be about you have to
spoil the original story also before I
tell you why I think it's good I have to
implore you not to watch the movie
version first I watched the movie after
I read the book which is fine but even
though it's a pretty close i dapped
ation
piñon is this is not the way you want to
experience the watchman universe for the
first time so what is watchman and why
do I think you should read it before the
HBO series comes out Watchmen was a
limited comic series written by Alan
Moore and David Gibbons for DC Comics it
was written as a story that had
brand-new characters and it has a
beginning a middle and an end as it was
designed as a 12 issue series and later
made into what we call now a graphic
novel it was first published in 1986
through 1987 and the first collected
volume of it was also in 1987 it's
essentially an alternate history where
superheroes exist they came around in
the 1940s and their presence has an
effect on the history that we know in
other words it's in the United States
there are several things pulled from
regular history but the existence of
domestic venturers or superheroes has
changed some things as well it was a
popular comic when it came out it got
good reviews from comic fans and from
the press at large outside of the world
of comic book it was listed in Time
magazine's list of the hundred best
novels as one of the best
english-language novels published since
1923 and you often hear people say
things like it's when comic books came
of age or when they grew up you know
like this idea that it was influential
and changing the landscape of comic
books and what became graphic novels
because it was different than what
people were used to it's basically not
what you would expect from a comic book
series and the characters are more
interesting than I would have guessed
it's deep but not necessarily
complicated
I definitely got pulled in and found
myself reading academic papers on the
philosophy and everything else but even
at face value I think if you like my
channel and the things I cover normally
you'll probably like this too if you're
already a fan that's great and hopefully
you'll see the potential for a great TV
series like I do the best non spoilery
take on the end is that it makes you
think it's a
very layered story the layering of the
story and the way it's presented sucks
you in the artwork the repeated
symbolism the nonlinear parts of the
narrative there are a lot of things
going on in this that I wouldn't have
expected from a comic book when I first
picked it up because of that the first
thing you realize at the end is that
you're gonna have to read this book
again and what's nice is that it's
actually self-contained you meet the
characters you figure out who they are
what drives them you get their origin
stories which are all neatly included
within the book itself and then at the
end that's it you know everything there
is to know about this universe the first
time I read it I read it in two sittings
I read it in two afternoons it's not a
quick read necessarily but it isn't this
giant tome that you have to read
multiple volumes or anything else there
are some other stories related to it
that came after the fact but I haven't
read anything to make that seem like
they would be Canon related to the TV
show so the only thing I'm actually
promoting here and talking about here
are the original twelve issues that are
collected in one trade paperback so why
do I think the show based on this comic
is going to be good again this is kind
of hard to do without spoiling things
but I think a lot of the themes that the
comic brings out will be easy to
transfer to today's world now I won't
totally go into it here because this
would be another video altogether but
essentially what's going on here is
Damon Lindelof is making a series that
takes place 30 or 35 years after the
events of what happened in the comic so
it's an alternate history based off an
alternate history the characters existed
they did what they did inside the book
and that has an effect on the world that
is depicted in the TV show some of those
characters will still be alive and
crossover some probably won't but I
think it's very safe to say that the
series will be in the same spirit as the
comic and that's why you need to read
the comic first some of the other
reasons I think
we'll be good are based on like I said I
was a huge fan of the leftovers that's a
situation where they adapted a book for
the first season more or less and then
branched off into something else based
on it being in the same universe very
similar to what we have here although
there's one big difference the author of
the book was involved with the series
and the author of Watchmen is famous for
not wanting anybody to adapt any of his
work into any other medium so it's safe
to say that he would not be involved in
the TV show or the crafting of the world
that exists in his universe that he
created nearly 35 years ago I personally
don't think this is the problem that a
lot of diehard comic book fans would
think it is for me I think it can be
done tastefully I think that it can be
pulled off but because this is such a
popular comic it's hallowed ground and
there's gonna be a big group of people
who just don't like it for that reason
but we'll see what happens we don't
really know until we know and I think
that all the promotional materials so
far is pretty good as far as not being
something that would take away from the
world that already exists now as far as
reading it you can get it online
obviously you can buy it I'll put some
links below in the comments I read the
original series just as it is they have
some other editions now that are
annotated and include extra information
there is also a animated motion comic
which is something that I didn't know
existed
they take the original artwork and they
put music to it and have a narrator so
it's read to you I did watch the
Watchmen motion comic and it's pretty
good but I don't think you should start
there because it actually leaves out a
lot of the supplementary stuff that's in
the original book there are parts at the
end of each issue that explain some of
the background of different characters
and things like that they're not drawn
in a comic they're more like you just
read them so those aren't included in
the motion comic so my plan from here is
to break down the trailer it's not new
anymore but
the stuff I saw about it was initial
reactions and there's more information
available now so just because I like
doing that anyways I'm gonna do a very
thorough breakdown of the trailer look
at what this series might actually be
about based on what we know from the
original story possibly look at the
characters and what their influences
might be going forward in this new world
we see that there are some images that
include some of these characters and
then some characters that are influenced
by those original characters so it'll be
good to just go through that plus maybe
a lot of people this is obviously a
popular book and millions of people are
read it already perhaps maybe they'll
want to refresh their memory on the book
that they read 20 years ago or whatever
but yes I am most excited about this
right now of course I have other plans
for the channel as well I'm going to be
doing mr. robot season 4 when that goes
out I've been covering that for a long
time and I'm really excited about its
final season I will pick up with
Westworld again next year
of course I'll also do the Game of
Thrones prequel series but that's still
a long way off at this point as far as
the main series it occurs to me that
most people don't like the ending that
Georgia or Martin has in mind
perhaps that's because they were hoping
for a more traditional fantasy story
ending so either way I'm not going to be
covering that for the time being I will
definitely read the remaining books and
I'm actually looking very forward to
that as soon as they come out and I'll
think about coverage related to those at
that time I'm thinking about doing the
expanse I've been reading those books
over the last few weeks and I'm
definitely interested in that series
which should be coming out in the next
few months on Amazon so I have a lot of
stuff planned but I'll tell you you know
Watchmen really sucked me in so I wanted
to give you guys a chance to have the
same experience I had read it absorb it
think about it and then pick up with
speculating on what the new series is
going to be about and that's what we'll
do so let me know what you think where
you're a fan of Watchmen before or have
you never heard of it are you excited
about reading it for the first time
since you found out that HBO is doing a
series on it
please like the video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and want to follow along
with Watchmen or any other TV shows I do
thanks for watching guys I will talk to
you soon